pas la face cachée du monde sort demain
en librairie un livre de 600 pages à
charge contre le quotidien du soir qui
est une institution dans le monde de la
presse sur la sellette les trois
dirigeants jean marie colombani à la
main et edwy plenel accusé je cite
d'abus de pouvoir de dénonciation à sens
unique
marie-pierre courtellemont a sélectionné
quelques révélations extraites de ce
pavé la charge est sévère
six cents pages au fil desquels pierre
péan et philippe cohen exposé leurs
griefs contre la direction du monde
deux hommes sont particulièrement dans
leur collimateur jean marie colombani et
edwy plenel ce dernier occupe
aujourd'hui le poste de directeur de la
rédaction du journal
c'est la vitrine d'un grand magasin
d'une grande surface
il faut que à l'intérieur on se balade
très bien que ce soit assez pédagogique
à ses clés mais pour comprendre dans le
magasin hockey beaucoup de clignotants
et c'est bien ce que les deux auteurs
reproche à edwy plenel de multiplier les
coups dont ils dénoncent les origines
les méthodes d'edwy plenel pour
fabriquer des scoops alliance avec des
assoiffés de pouvoir instrumentalisation
d'un juge
échange de bons procédés avec des
policiers c'est en écho n en veulent
pour preuve les liens plus qu'étroits
kids with lainelle aurait noué dans les
années 80 avec bernard deleu place
leader d'un syndicat policier
selon eux le journaliste du monde serait
intervenu dans la stratégie de la fast
en rédigeant des articles anonyme dans
le journal du syndicat un mélange des
genres contraire selon les auteurs à la
déontologie journalistique
tout au long du livre edwy plenel est
décrit comme un être manipulateur qui
aurait étouffé des dossiers quand cela
l'arrangé
faisons de roi ou briseur de carrière au
gré de ses intérêts ainsi le quotidien
se serait mis au service de la campagne
présidentielle d'edouard balladur en
en sélectionnant soigneusement les
informations les plus favorables au
candidat la corse comment peut-elle
prendre sa place dans la corse est l'une
des passions de jean marie colombani
à tel point selon les auteurs du livre
qu'il en aurait fait illégalement
pendant quelques années sa résidence
fiscale ses revenus 3 millions de francs
annuels déclaré aux
pour sur une île qui multiplient les
avantages fiscaux inadmissible selon les
deux journalistes de la part d'un homme
qui fustige la malhonnêteté de certains
hommes politiques
jean marie colombani sera finalement
épinglé par le fisc
et puis il ya la sphère du quotidien
gratuit 20 minutes pour accueillir ce
nouveau journal dans ses imprimeries
jean marie colombani aurait promis aux
propriétaires de 20 minutes de vanter
ses mérites dans les colonnes du monde
la négociation compliquée à chopra
colombani et aurait alors publié un
éditorial vengeurs avant finalement
d'obtenir un accord scandale selon les
auteurs du livre
pendant que docteur jekyll jean marie
rappelle à longueur d'éditorial les
règles de l'équité de la libre
concurrence les principes de loyauté et
de transparence
mr hyde colombani monnaie à la façon
d'un chef de clan ses relations et sa
capacité de nuire à la fin du livre
pierre péan et philippe cohen accuse les
dirigeants du monde d'habiller les
mauvais résultats du journal par une
présentation trompeuse des comptes
les deux auteurs se disent d'autant plus
choqué que le journal ne s'est pas privé
d'épingler enron et divin autant
d'éléments qui font écrire à pierre péan
et philippe cohen que l'esprit du
fondateur du journal
hubert beuve méry a déserté les couloirs
du monde